i still don't really understand like the
potential of the internet you're always
underestimating the power of what you're
doing today
if you're being consistent and putting
stuff out you're always underestimating
the fractal crazy effects that
show up months and months or years later
in some cases and i think this is
another idea that i've always struggled
to articulate but
the just the notion that you did
something for 12 months
consistently if nobody interacts with it
i would honestly challenge anybody
on the planet if you did something every
day for 365 days like some creative
exercise and posted it
if you couldn't create one commercial
opportunity off the back of that
i just don't think it's possible
the british are coming the british are
here i've arrived
we have arrived here we have was it
harder to grow
a business to 100 grand a month or to
deal with a newborn baby newborn baby
10 times over i think really incredible
man
just like everything you take for
granted watching even people in the
street with babies
it's like everybody has babies you know
how difficult can it be
it's freaking hard that's hard
what's been the biggest challenge uh
i think just like handing over your
agency or just like just completely
absolving yourself of agency for a
period of time
where the baby is in control right the
baby dictates how the day is gonna go
this is not a uh hey this is the
schedule for today it's like you don't
make those decisions
anymore baby's making those decisions at
least for a
couple months right at the start you're
uh
you are on a different set of rules than
you
had ever imagined you would be on
beforehand
um underestimated that to some degree
but we're we're we're at 14 weeks now so
we're sort of arriving at uh
actually we're recording this he broke a
record last night his longest sleep ever
so uh
congratulations nine hours in two
minutes so you're tracking your baby's
sleep if you've got an aura ring on him
he's got more equipment than you could
possibly imagine
that's cool so talk to me about lessons
right you
this sort of one-man band running
visualize value and all of the other
stuff that you do
and then you add fatherhood into the mix
what is some of the lessons that you've
learned from that
i think um a lot of
the business today has been based on
this concept of using the internet to
create leverage like divorce your time
and income
create products not services
and those concepts all
are incredibly
they're incredibly valuable to a
business but there is
the connection between your time and the
result is still
very obvious when you take a a step back
from
building those things so um
big lessons one was just how much
how much uninterrupted focus can
lead to these likes seemingly small
things that create
big uh results down the road so
um you know you could be walking around
for
four or five hours or sort of just like
on the computer messing around
reading something and then an idea just
comes to you those periods of time are
drastically compressed
after you're you know in a situation
where there's a human being depending on
you and my wife
does an incredible job of like holding
back
the tidal wave there but at the
beginning of the process
it was very much a uh you know the
baby's in the room with you you get like
90 minutes at a time before stuff kicks
off and uh
that is like i think you start to
reflect on the fact that
the space that the space that i had
before
led to a lot of the um you know the best
work is not necessarily
i think morgan hauser talks about this
it's uh it's not when you're doing the
work it's all the thinking that you do
for days on end and then you just arrive
at this epiphany
and you're you know when a child is
really small and you're
looking after it then those windows to
create epiphanies are drastically
compressed
so you feel like at the start there it's
like am i ever gonna get
um like 90 minutes of clear thought
time and that's also a product of it
being your first baby and you're like
uh you know you can't walk two steps
away are you really
um nervous and i've heard these stories
about people have their second baby in
the hospital and they're just like oh
yeah i'd be fine you know but when
you're like first-time parents you're
just
panicking about oh he's making that
noise he's making this noise is he all
right
you need to call somebody and uh you're
just you just realize how much like
subconscious
like uh how much work your subconscious
was doing previously because it was
unencumbered with like the thought of
having to protect and raise another
human being so
just that like leveling out over time
has uh
has been a big adjustment and also just
looking at time
in a different way so it's like if you
have an hour
be a lot more intentional with how you
use that hour if you can
you know and sometimes that's not
possible but um
yeah it definitely gives you an instant
perspective shift
in the short term and you know
what might what might what am i doing
what i want to teach somebody how do you
want
like what you want the trajectory of
your life to be now that you're
in a very different situation than you
were a few months previous so
yeah i mean it's the the shift in
thinking
is kind of profound in every direction
it's hard to even
articulate a lot of the the different
mental models that emerge as a result of
it it's such a multi-polar
multi-discipline
multi-modal change right you've just got
all of these inputs and experiences
layered with emotions and all manner of
other things it doesn't surprise me that
it's hard to
condense down especially as someone who
does this for a living right like you
synthesize complex ideas as a job that's
your
that's your profession yeah you're
struggling to do it
i think as well an interesting takeaway
from what you've just said there
is to go back to deep work that cal
newport says he talks about how
social media particularly can fragment
your days
into blocks of time so small that it's
impossible to get any meaningful work
done at all
to some people who perhaps have a less
mindful relationship with their social
media feed than you do
their twitter is your child
constantly crying in the background
constantly permeating the subconscious
just this ambient anxiety that oh i
might have a notification or
oh i need to check whatever's whatever's
happening online
yeah no absolutely i i think uh
there you can you can have those tracks
running
with a level of importance assigned to
them that is not
consistent with how important they
actually are right this is
an exception to the rule
the problem is over time you habituate
you just that myelin gets wrapped so
hard in your brain
and it gets wired down so hard that it
no longer is a conscious decision
it was just a race to the bottom of the
brain stem and now
you just type in tw on your uh your
browser thing before you even know it
which everyone's got right everyone's
got the tw
reflex t in the lower cases you've
gotten down to two
okay fair enough so but i was the the
other uh the other thing that makes me
think of is um
is those things become
so so much a part of your routine that
you it's difficult to
subtract them from what the actual
driver of progress is right it's like it
almost becomes a part of the pattern
so heavily that you're like if i stop
doing that then
this result is going to stop showing up
and
it's because it's tapping on so many of
those like primal
i'm not a biologist but there is
countless numbers
of reports research like
into how much that is like drilled into
your biology at this point it's so hard
to separate it and i've gone through
a number of like feasts and famines or
like fasts
on like social stuff and
the idea that staying stuck in that
feedback loop
is good for the long-term results of a
business is
a myth in most cases so many people
myself included struggle to work out
what the effective inputs are that are
causing the right outputs to occur
and my industry nightlife right it is
so messy to work out there's no such
thing as direct marketing
there's the brand everything you do is
branding right so you have
no idea why is a night cool why is an
event cool
no one knows it just is just you know
then it's not cool right
well yeah exactly if you know you don't
know um and
it's so what we're trying to do we're
like me my business partner have this
conversation every year
do we need to spend as much as we are on
and then pick any different category on
guest listings on
online marketing on physical marketing
on djs on bookings on celebrity pas on
whatever it is and we always come back
to
i don't know because i don't know what's
causing the knight to be effective
but systemically from a habit sense a
lot of the time
especially if you've found a modicum of
success
what you can do is go right nobody
[ __ ] move
nobody move at all just stay right where
you are
continue to do the thing that you're
doing because it is
this appears to be less broken than it
was before so let's not try and fix it
yeah spot on i think the smaller the
business the more that's true right
because you haven't crossed the
chasm into systems and delegation to the
point where
you can start to
[Music]
you can start to identify what's working
and what isn't but
i think there's also this weird middle
ground between something being really
special and unique
and small which produces cool things
typically and then these behemoths
are more commoditized like low margin
businesses that
have spent decades making systems and
you can
get stuck in the middle really easily
and i built a business like that a few
years ago and it was
absolutely horrible like productize
agency service business
it's just the most brutal thing you can
imagine and it's just a race
to the bottom so uh yeah it's uh
that this whole idea of the creator
economy or being the
the solo capitalist all of those traps
are very very dangerous and hard to
avoid for sure
what else did you learn any other things
from integrating fatherhood
moms men moms are just unbelievable
my wife's resilience is just like
just next level man like you i think uh
somebody told me the other week
they've got a really good friend who was
like seal team
six uh you know like insane
top-tier military veteran had his first
baby
a few months ago and he's like this is
the most brutal thing i've ever
tops out yeah it's like can you even
and you're the dude in the relationship
it's like you don't have the like the
biological
um you know physical stress that that um
[Music]
mom goes through and it's just
remarkable to watch
and you have just a newfound
appreciation for your own mum for
everybody else
that has raised a child people that are
raising kids on their own it's just
just remarkable man that's definitely
the biggest takeaway is like
mercenaries moms mercenaries just total
killers
what about taking time off then so you
have this
child you want to be a good dad you want
to spend time with them
you also want to enjoy the experience
right you know this is the first time
you're going to have the only time
you're going to have a first child
so you think i want to immerse myself in
this which presumably meant you took
time away from the business yeah but
there's algorithm loops occurring here
there's the fear of being less seen
did you get anxiety about spending time
off so
interestingly enough like the first few
weeks i was like i didn't really
i was really focused on like what's the
high leverage
stuff right like what are the like two
or three things i can send out a day
or where can i pull like stuff from the
archives hasn't been out for two years
and just surface it back up
and that kind of kept the momentum going
and you're running on adrenaline for a
little while the first few weeks it's
like i can
get on my phone for 15 minutes and then
you're just so wired that you can go
back and experience
fully um like family time too
and then when the toll
start or when the like sleep deprivation
starts to catch up with you it's like
while i was talking about the beginning
of the conversation where are these
original thoughts going to come from and
where is the
like the window of time to start to um
you know when's that start to open up so
you can start to produce at the same
level you were before uh yeah you start
to think
man am i ever gonna recover or i'm ever
gonna get back
to that rhythm that i was in before and
um
yeah you start to realize that there's
logically the risk is low right there's
like you've built a huge network you can
go back and
kind of there's this anti-fragility to
building an online business and a brand
under your own name which would
short of like nuclear fallout disaster
there's not i'm not really worried about
opportunity on a grand scale it's like
even
like freelance clients or whatever else
but to
sort of lose the momentum of a of a huge
thing is something that you start to get
anxious about it's uh
[Music]
because like you say the the the way
your content gets shown and you work on
youtube which i think is even more
brutal than something like a twitter
where there is some element of
um i won't say meritocracy but if you
get the
if you plug into the right thing at the
right time you can have these outsized
results right whereas youtube is the
grinders like
like you have to get this many people
watching it for this this percent of
time
over this period uh he's so at the mercy
of the algorithm on youtube i think more
than any other platform
yeah and um i i i started to get that
youtube momentum maybe a year ago and i
i've not come back to youtube very
seriously
because of that because it's like man i
need to really decide to do it and
pursue it properly
um but yeah you start to see it showing
up all over the place
and yeah it's just a reframing
of reframing in general i think
the the world is changing in a lot of
ways too when you think about that like
feast feast and fast mode of
creativity and in the type that like the
type of business that i've built
you really can do like a month of
intense work do a launch and then go
go away for three six months make
something come back that's never been
how i've operated but i don't think
that's not an option so it's kind of
sean pury had this really great uh
analogy where he's like if you have like
a loyal
network of people you have essentially a
stem cell
so you can use it to
produce anything you want right you
could turn that into this execution or
this product or you could
build a community or you could like sell
physical product there's all these
different ways that you can
like apply this uh
these relationships that you've built at
scale but if you're just used to
this like muscle repetition that you've
been in you you lose sight of some of
those other possible executions so
if the if the situation changes
you have to zoom out a little bit and be
like okay so there's
there's still like did you see that tim
urban
graphic the weight but why the path
dependency
thing yeah it's very very uh
that kind of conjures up that image in
my mind too it's like
you've gotten here by posting six
images a day to twitter but you don't
have to get there by continuing to do
that necessarily if that makes sense
yeah it's it's so interesting when it
goes back to the right we found some
success
please nobody change anything and
especially as a one-man army
you think well there's only me and my
own eroticism
to deal with with this i've just got my
own thought loops
and no one really to pull me out of it
you know when
one of the advantages i suppose that you
get other than scale and the ability to
pass work down to people and delegate
and stuff like that one of the
advantages you get
is the patent break within your own
neuroticism in a business
if you have a conversation with somebody
else and they go well
let me just challenge you on on that
idea for a second because i'm i'm not
sure but
you you are only you right and you're
holding on to this success that you've
built bread and butter ground floor up
you've
seen it every single step of the way sat
there on
photoshop or after effects or whatever
it is that you're doing continuously
iterating and coming up with ideas
and then somehow you need to have a new
perspective because
because there's a child in the mix yeah
and
like abandoning the uh
abandoning the thing that works in in
favor of
something uncertain when you're weighing
up the cost of the time
you you know the time you get back
versus
the you know the momentum that you
forego
and i'm like my wife is
uh it's like an incredible feedback loop
and
none of this would have happened on the
business side without her either it's
like
that doing it like really solo
is is just probably incredibly intense
and i
imagine there are very few people that
have no form of like local
feedback loop this like that's been a
huge huge
advantage um did you notice yeah did you
notice drop-off then
with regards to reach or conversions or
whatever with
twitter and with instagram during that
break
yeah pretty i mean you can map it on a
graph it's like we move we moved house
in august of last year as well and the
charts going like that
and then we moved the month it just
completely tanks and then
it's back up again because you just um
there's there's leverage but there isn't
um
momentum there isn't just like imaginary
momentum happening right you you can you
can create a leverage result but you're
not like
i think that's this myth of passive
income that people talk about where it's
like oh i wanna i wanna build passive
incomes like
you can build leveraged income and maybe
there are some forms of passive income
that open up to you when you have
just absurd amounts of capital for
example but
to live off of passive income when
you're starting out
is is a myth in my opinion you need
to pursue leveraged income where
input is disconnected from output in
just an outrageous it's like how clever
you can be rather than just how hard you
can
grind dude that's a bomb i really really
like that the fact that
people get confused with passive income
what they think is
input free outcomes
that's not what that's not what you get
you just get to overly magnify the
inputs
yeah and i think if you've if you've
managed to create leverage
income for long enough that you have
access to truly passive
investments that is possible but it's
like rarefied it's not within it's not
within the creator economy it's not
within the things that we're talking
about here
david perrell can't do right of passage
and not be there
that people are there for david perrell
like he i had a conversation with him
the other week and he was like dude for
two months
of the year twice a year i i stopped my
life
all i do is right of passage ali abdul
with his part-time youtuber
uh academy that the guy just lives and
breathes and his team now that he's got
this huge big fat team because these
cohort based courses are
significantly more resource intensive
than a
yeah obviously just a buy and pay to
play type thing and man these guys just
that's it
that's their life for a period so yes
it's leveraged income yes there is a
degree of passivity to it because
you don't have to be there as each
person buys
but it's just magnification not true
passiveness yeah and you're like maybe
your labor
slowly reduces over time or the
intensity of your
like the necessity of your physical
presence but then that will switch to
mental presence right then you have to
be a great operator and that's still
that's still effort and decision-making
and yeah judgment at scale rather than
just uh leveraged via some
technology like being able to broadcast
by video something like that it's like
building a team that can keep doing that
i suppose that means that you need to
love the grind and you need to
love the work even more so because a lot
of the time
people look at the this is pointless
graph for instance from visualized value
and they
presume that okay so once i hit
inflection point and i get these
to the moon gains i then get to take my
foot off the gas
and the rocket continues to go up and
you're like no
you just get to magnify the amount of
effort versus output outcome that you
get
yeah yeah it's uh what is it the matthew
principle
to more will be given to those who
have everything yeah yeah yeah yeah what
are some of the unseen challenges with
your type of business
forget the child what are some of the
things that
people wouldn't think or don't see that
you
face i think you touched on it there i
think it's the
um the
shiny objects is definitely one so
you'll get to a point where
it makes very little sense to do
um but it makes it you really have to be
good at identifying what the leveraged
things are and that and it gets it gets
dicey after a period of time where
um
trying to think of a concrete example
here so
building like building the
mvp of a product and getting it out
then getting stuck in like the
iterations of that product for example
is like i i don't know the exact phrase
but it's like
um there's such a marginal return on all
of that tweaking
that should be spent on you know getting
feedback from people building
relationships with people meeting new
people
um i think that
the inability to zoom out and recognize
what the le what the true points of
leverage are
i think maybe the biggest takeaway is
the
the idea of of self promotion so i think
this is another thing in the
that could be extracted from that graph
it's like past a certain point you think
that
everybody's out there doing your
promotion work for you right everybody's
out there talking about your stuff and
hey like i've published this many
episodes so now everything's going to
take care of itself
and it's pretty remarkable like even
with a really sizable reach
like the the world a world that moves at
the speed of the internet will forget
about you
in 15 minutes if you don't keep showing
up
so how do you maintain this sense of
perspective
you have certain things as a small
number of tasks
or operations that you do that add the
most value that achieve the most
leverage
how do you avoid being caught up in the
shiny object syndrome
it's a hard one i think there is some
weird responsibility to allocate a
certain amount of time
to pursuing shiny objects i've
discovered in the last like
six months or so so um there are certain
things that are trained
are changing at a macro level that you
want to stay
um plugged into essentially
but the perspective i think that's
helpful is that just
understanding what the like what the
engine is and for me that's like
producing
the visuals for you that would be like
recording the and publishing the
interviews and
sometimes in pursuit of those
in pursuit of those shiny objects that
aren't that isn't it's not the work
itself right it's just a different way
to deploy the work or a different way to
think about the work or different medium
for the work
none of it is a replacement and i think
where we lose perspective is when we
start to think of it as a
replacement for doing the work itself
so that's constantly how i find
perspective
and um like reset that is like okay none
of this would have happened if i didn't
show up and
make these images and post them every
day it's that simple you just go back to
that it's like if i'm
lost or i'm like oh momentum is waning
somewhere
it's like go on pick up a book find like
10 ideas that are resonating with you
get in front of the computer
turn them into visuals post them and
then like all of these
opportunities that will come three six
nine months down the road
you may not know exactly what those
things are but
the one thing that you have to commit to
is the
you know the catalyst that's going to
bring the opportunities to you and i
think we can
sort of lose perspective that that's the
input that's that's generating those
outputs down the road and that this is
pointless graph is
is essentially trying to illustrate that
like i could not
have possibly predicted
the naval book is a great example right
the like starting to
post these images of ideas that naval's
published as a way to
find these tiny consulting gigs to get
people to pay me to like design a
landing page for them
nine months later there's a like i have
an illustrator credit and a book
on amazon it's like that's nuts and that
was never ever like i did not pursue
that opportunity by
directly so it's about like this uh
you're pursuing something and then all
of these opportunities kind of
start to pop out at you indirectly as a
result of you just
like practicing in public one of the
things
that i've noticed again going back to
the club promo
example me and my business partner used
to
tell people to come to nightclubs for a
long time we didn't have
managers i would manage all of the
networkers and then over time you're
like
okay well if we're gonna run two or
three or four nights a week i need to
scale myself up right so i need to get
some managers in between me and the
networkers because i can't manage 500
members of staff that are all guest
listing for us
and then okay well i mean if we've got
11 managers or 12 managers
and four nights we probably could do
with a night manager that'll look after
each of them
and it's that story i think it's from
the e-myth where there's a lady that has
a bakery
and she wants to build a bakery factory
or something and then
three years later she goes in to have a
look at the people making the
the bakery stuff that loves the bread
and she she they don't know who she is
she hasn't got a clue how the bread's
made anymore
and a lot of the time i think we use
that paradigm
as an individual creator we take the
paradigm of the big business
and we throw that over the top we get so
caught up operationally day-to-day
dealing with emails dealing with
the back and forth perfect example for
the podcast is dealing with advertisers
and recording the pre-roll intros like
that's
what generates the majority of the
revenue have you paid your invoice
what are the talking points that we need
to talk about have i tried the product
do i think the product's any good or not
back and forth with them what rates are
we going for how long is it going to
happen
and that takes up just as much energy
and time and effort as the thing which
is the reason that you are successful
and have enabled those opportunities in
the first place
right and focusing on the core
and staying as lean as possible i mean
it's a it's an argument
for just uncomplicating the entire
business process
to have a single product one thing
perhaps or one channel you know and
i think um anthony pompliano has done
this quite well in that
he did one network at the time is that
right i'm gonna crush
twitter i'm gonna crush podcasting james
clear as well
i'm gonna crush blogging then i'm gonna
crush newsletter then i'll do book and i
think he's now about to start podcasting
or something like that
so yeah some of the smartest people are
constraining
the amount of shiny objects and
operations that they can become
distracted by because they know
over time you will end up doing so much
of the ancillary [ __ ] around the outside
that somebody who doesn't have those
complications will come in
and punch a hole in the middle of what
you were supposed to be the market
leader for
yeah i think uh it's
osmosis it's like oh serious businesses
or proper businesses do this like i need
more skus i need like more channels and
it
it's like reading a buzzfeed article on
how to be a good marketer right it's
like do this on facebook and do that on
twitter and
it's like it's not really advice it
doesn't
actually say anything it's more like
figure out like figure out the engine
and we talked about the
like if there's some selfish component
to that engine
then that's how you
win either way right the the
ability to turn an idea into a visual
it's not something that is only
commercially viable
or monetizable through a twitter account
it's like a thing that you can
do for people on a one-to-one basis so
you have this like
net that sits below the thing you're
doing and you're adding leverage to it i
think
it's very easy to get distracted by
um or i don't i don't know your
exact story but you were doing something
else as well as building up
this podcasting empire that is now
you know six figure subscribers on
youtube it wasn't like
hey i'm chris and i'm starting this
business i'm quitting everything else
and i'm just gonna start my youtube
channel
because that would have been you would
have uh ballsy
yeah ballsy but also like incredibly
difficult to monetize from day one right
that
idea that concentrating your efforts
until
something becomes much easier to point
out
as an asset to monetize rather than this
like sprawling
beast where you don't really know where
the
the points of leverage are so it's yeah
the rules
the rules don't apply the the same way
to the individual
creator as they do the you know the
small business or the big business and
that's people read a lot of books with
those rules in them and
and follow them and lose the edge that
they
would have created otherwise which is um
you know the internet has enabled a very
different type of business to exist and
be monetized
than something that needs 15 middle
managers to operate
all of the rules are out of the window
there i really wonder it's got me
thinking whether there's a
an argument to be made that you
constrain
the upper bound on how much you grow or
how many different things you try and do
you have all of these potential
opportunities that are going to come to
you
but they might arrive before you finish
dominating
the core or before you've reached an uh
a degree of power law
inflection that is high enough
that it's it's unfailable now nothing
nothing can add weight to the bottom of
this rocket where we're
going to the moon like jump on board and
um
i would guess that most creators unless
you are incredibly disciplined or
single-minded or absolutely
adore the thing that you do will start
to see these opportunities coming in and
see them as viable business
strategies well look this is this is
what traditional
precisely and then that's when the
rocket starts to run out of speed
there could be a way you could imagine a
world in which
you spent all of your time dealing with
customer inquiries about
courses and um having calls with
interesting people that want to just
talk about your visuals and
little side projects and this that and
the other and end up dedicating
single digit hours per week or less to
the thing
that makes you renowned on the internet
and the same goes for the podcast
spending all the time speaking to the
advertisers or
dealing with guests or scheduling or
whatever it is it's like look did you
make this work when you first started
yes what was the thing why is what is
the reason that people come to you what
is the very very core of the product
because this is the difference right
when you think about someone like nike
nike have shoes but their shoes really
aren't that much different to an adidas
parachute or a puma parachute
what you're buying are all of the
ancillary benefits right and the outside
of the onion
the reverse is true in the creator
economy everybody's got
the extraneous stuff because people can
make nice podcast artwork or people can
get the same people can even get the
same guests as you
can have the same guests as you they can
read the same books that you do and
summarize them
what is the thing that you have what is
the uvp
that you bring to the market that's the
thing that you need to continue focusing
on
yeah i uh was thinking about this idea
the other day
and david perrell i think labeled this
maybe
as good as it's ever gonna be labeled
the personal monopoly
you have the personal monopoly and then
you have the monopoly so the other idea
i was thinking about
is you have amazon and then you have the
artisan
these are like the barbell ends of the
economy that we're
barreling towards it's like if you
have a you know to quote a
the gnarly jeff bezos your margin is my
opportunity
right the any business that traffic
commodities in any definition is gonna
get eaten up by amazon
short of some regulatory body standing
in the way like
animals and hospitals amazon everything
versus the you know three billion media
brands
that people can start and maybe it's not
exclusive to just media but it's
like the very small
um media is probably the best example
the vet the very small
media business that is the only way you
avoid being a commodity is leaning
into something so extremely specific
that people can't get anywhere else
whether that's like your personality
whether it's like the creative
output of your process of some kind or
it's you the way you end up
the way you analyze a company um there's
great examples of
of that all over twitter of people that
do the same thing as the wall street
journal in
in essence right if for the uninformed
observer the wall street journal is
going to give you a report on a business
and so is
someone like [ __ ] mccormick or mario
gabrielle
but people pay hundreds of dollars a
year to read
uh pakis analysis because he's funny or
like they like the way he looks at the
world
um but you can easily get stuck in the
middle of that
chasm in like uh you know sort of
mediocre publishing firm that doesn't
really stand out from either of the two
so it feels like maybe i'm so close to
it that i feel like it's
happening really fast but it does feel
like a trend that is
that has taken hold at this point do you
suffer with product fatigue
obviously you've got these courses that
you put out now those are one of the big
drivers of revenue for you but you need
to
no one's going to buy a course twice
right yeah it's definitely
a it's it
definitely a huge consideration so
also there's some ethical thing there
where a lot of my knowledge is in these
two things at this point so
like i had the 10-year career and then
produced two products that summarized
what i learned in 10 years
and i'm still learning between when i
published those and now
but those learnings are really
modifications to the products that
already exist
they're not brand new things or at least
i don't feel comfortable
making them into brand new things and
the thing you have to square with that
is like the market get the market is
like their attention span is so low so
it's like that stuff is old
at this point and you'll see you know
businesses like
i won't name any names right but some
people will put out
25 30 courses on
kind of the same thing maybe framed a
little bit differently new name new
cover
new guest speaker um in order to just
keep the attention of the market
which you know you can make an argument
that that's like
the market makes the decision like if
they buy it then great
uh but personally like it
just does not fire me up so i'm
always
i'm now like maybe 50 50. so there's
product development there's like
community stuff that has existed from
the first round of
visualize value products and then 50
of my time is spent on like what is the
next thing what are the new
mediums that i can go and take a massive
risk on for six months because i have
a parachute and then i can bring that
knowledge back to
people that maybe are where i was two
three four years ago
if we continue to go the knowledge route
um there's also just like this is a
whole other rabbit hole
like a lot of web 3 technologies that
i've been introduced to the nft stuff
like that whole crypto market is
fascinating to me right now which is uh
[Music]
causing a like circle of learning
and uh trying to figure out how to how
to dive into that world too so
yeah product fatigue is definitely real
and
the way to it's just a difficult thing
to address in a world that has
like a really really short attention
span it's very hard to address
product fatigue unless you're in a
publishing business that's
you know like your business is a perfect
example of this it's like
you do the same thing over and over
again you love doing it
and it always produces new output over
time
and in a way like visualize value
gets more diluted the more it produces
if that makes sense
like some of the some of the things i
really want people to take on board
that help me like there's
you you could argue that you do a
disservice at a certain point by
adding too much there's only so many
ways that you can describe
the same concepts right and the issue
that you have as an individual creator
that is completely
self-powered as you are as opposed to
the way that i am where i get to ride
off the back of each person that i speak
to
you have a upper bound on your
inspiration level
you have an upper bound on your life
experience as well
yeah yeah and we've talked about this
before but i think it's so fascinating
the difference between a media
the type that i do where i get to
continuously get extra little turbo
boosts on mario kart i just jump on it
like oh it's a jordan peterson turbo
booster no no it's a jack butcher turbo
boost now to seth gordon turbo boost
and all that i need to do is just be a
mirror for that energy
i get to take all that they're doing and
you kind of just become a bit of a
pedestal or a platform
and even if you look to
youtubers you know you look to the ali
abdolls of the world they're
kind of still doing that there's a
little bit more distance between them
and the person that they're talking
about the concept that they're talking
about
but there's more degrees of freedom with
regards to how they can communicate
those conversations and and those topics
um
but yeah it really is
there's something that you lose from
being a a podcaster
specifically in that it's the least
viral of all of the
creator industries as far as i can see
like if you want to make money fast
podcasting is not the way to go because
it just
there's no associated virality with it
specifically not on audio
but what you do get is insane longevity
because you essentially have a
bottomless pit of interesting people to
speak to
i'm never going to run out of
interesting people to speak to you know
rogan's what 1800 episodes in still
going like an absolute champ
three episodes four episodes a week
sometimes two episodes in a day
sometimes
because he can and because he's got this
curiosity that is his driver internally
and he gets this extra engine that comes
from the other people
whereas when you are this solo creator
which
you know you have
become a role model i'm sure for tons
and tons of people that think right [ __ ]
it
i am ditching the shitty job that i do
not like i don't want to spend my time
here anymore
jack butcher made it happen i can make
it happen which is awesome like that's
fantastic
but you are still on the upward curve
of that hockey stick what people haven't
yet
seen is what it sounds like we're now
beginning to encounter which is
okay first set of rocket boosters have
fallen away now how do i
apply the second fuel cell to keep me
going
yeah yes it's a good analogy the idea
that um
i think this is an unattributed quote
it's like young people have ideas old
people have money
so you see this transition happen
everywhere it's like people make
money and then they become investors or
they have
like this feedback loop beneath them
where
you know you build a network and then
you can power
the network behind you with you know
that have
kind of a slight take thing that you uh
you built up or deploying your expertise
in a new way
uh i think these like and web3 is a good
example of this like these
what is web3 i have no idea what that is
so
so i'll do a horrible job explaining it
but
essentially the the evolution of the web
the best description i've heard the
shortest description i've heard web 1.0
is information links
right so it's if you publish information
you can link information
you can link from one article to another
from one institution to another at
universities used web 1.0 web 2.0 is
social links so it's
hey um i twitter facebook like i know
chris i met chris we've built a
relationship that way i've published a
bunch of podcasts
and then web 3.0 is economic links so
it's like experimenting with new ways to
incentivize people to create so there's
like decentralized organizations being
incorporated where you have
you know people working on a project in
15 different countries they raise money
from
everywhere and then they give back a
portion
of what they earn on the first round of
their project to everybody that backed
it so it's kind of
just stripping away some of the
formality of building
businesses and um that is just creating
a bunch of
like crazy
new ways to do things online so nfts is
like the
you know the most i think the the
shortest leap
for people to understand what web 3.0 is
like how does a digital artist start to
collect revenue for their work but
the the nuances that you can achieve
with a smart contract
are far beyond like selling a piece of
physical art so it could be 15 people
make this piece of art and then
they all split the proceeds and then as
this thing gets
licensed and used in other places
there's a contract that pays them
royalties so
um all of the like monetization
structures that
youtube for example are taking i don't
know what percent now probably something
crazy but
they give you a ton of distribution so
it makes sense is there's a
logical argument as to why they take
some of that but
um this new ecosystem that is being
built
i think is uh is playing into that idea
of like one plus one equals
three in some cases so like where i end
up
after booster set of boosters one falls
off
might be oh this person is publishing a
book
that is that would really benefit from
having these
their ideas visualized for example so
i'm going to enter into an agreement
with them
where i want x percent of the sales of
this book and then
um we get into some mutually
incentivized not to say you couldn't do
that without crypto but it just makes it
easier and um
even digital access to this content can
be
uh you know you can monetize it and get
rewarded for it so
it still feels to me like there's going
to be a huge power law
um a huge power law distribution among
the people that
make it to one side of the curve and
don't as in everything else
but um there's some really interesting
technology being developed to
uh just change some incentive structures
in in building creative work on the
internet and i i'm not an expert by any
means
i would love to send some links for
anybody that wants to
read about it because there's a lot of
people smarter than me that have written
about it and uh
yeah we'll see where it goes send them
over i'll put it in the
show notes below one of the things we've
talked about today a lot has
been this sort of power law and this
inflection point graph and
most people have some form of real world
example
of this hockey stick of returns i have
mine you have yours pretty much everyone
has theirs as well
can you take us back to before you hit
the inflection point where you were at
the this is pointless
bit of the visualized value graph can
you remember the sort of thoughts that
you had
around then yeah i think
if we talk about it in the specific
context of an internet business
this is before you really understand
that the power of network effects
is how i can now like retroactively
look at it so you're only experiencing
the downside of network effects at the
beginning
like you're embarrassed to publish stuff
like
you're i've got screenshots of the stuff
i was posting on facebook
three years ago and my mom is the only
person who's interacting with it
and you look back at that now you're
like why am i putting like i would go
out and meet people and they're like
how are you doing now like you quit your
job and now all i see you doing is like
posting uh like are you a motivational
speaker someone asked me once i was like
no no
i'm working on a design agency
and i'm like oh right cool good luck and
it was just like
it was it was freaking brutal man it's
like you publish this stuff
and nobody interacts with it but
now in hindsight it's like one it
thickens your skin which is a totally
different
conversation um but two there's this
network effect happening that you can't
even fathom
like there are people that won't even
interact with the stuff you're doing but
they're consuming it right like if you
um this is actually a link that i'll
send
this is thesis that someone wrote about
uh branding
where you think about i think george
mack wrote about this in his email
recently where he says there's a
different version of you that exists
inside everybody's head that you've ever
met
like your mom has a different version of
you than your
significant other than like the person
who reads your tweets then whoever else
right there's all these different
abstractions of you
and i think when you're at the this is
pointless phase
you are creating those abstractions but
you can't really
fathom the long-term consequences
of those like of of all of those
individual like
ideas that you're planting or all of
those like connections that you're
making
because somebody has probably got a name
for this but there's like a social cost
to interacting with your content when
it's not popular
so it's seen as low status right
yeah so that breaking that i i have no
idea when that
inflection point comes but it it in
you know in people that are having this
conversation it did come
at a certain point and um
the other part of it for me was the cost
associated with like a few people not
really understanding what i was doing
was lower to me than having time and
economic
freedom right so that was the
everything's a trade-off and that was
what i was trading was
like being misunderstood for like
rolling the dice at that point at being
free
so the
the early payoffs of stuff like that
were private conversations that people
reach out to me they wouldn't interact
with the stuff like hey jack
i like what you're doing you need to
explain to me how you might like
approach something for my business in
this vein
and it you know it's hundreds of reps
before you get a conversation like that
and it's
because you believe somebody that's done
it in front of you like i didn't do this
out of nowhere like i saw people doing
it i listened to people who are
inspiring it
um so seth godin's books i read in
maybe 2017 the dip um
when did this is marketing come out i
think that was a bit later but um
read a lot of his stuff and i was like
you know what this guy's like
maybe my favorite like my favorite
writer
and he seems to he seems to have done
all right for himself i know i
i'm not on that level by any means like
i can't articulate
ideas the way he could and
but you know what the
maybe there's just a few like shifts in
perspective along the way where it's
like i only need 10 people to believe in
me
to have like a six-figure consulting
business
so do i
keep posting stuff on facebook for a few
more months and try and get a few more
clients
or do i go back to work at a job
and uh so were you at this at this point
were you
conscious are you cognizant of that
perspective had you sat down with
yourself beforehand
and said some people are not going to
get this this is a trade-off which is
worthwhile
how much of this is being post-hoc
rationalized
um no i think i had that at the time i
think i was experiencing it at the time
and i really didn't get it um i had
lunch with someone on sunday who runs a
business that has a i know four million
email subscribers
and they were like yeah you know i still
don't really understand
like the potential of the internet it's
like just crazy man like you're always
behind the puck
right you're always underestimating
the power of what you're doing today if
you're being consistent and putting
stuff out you're always underestimating
the just fractal like
crazy effects that show up months and
months or years later in some cases and
i think
this is another idea that i've always
struggled to articulate but
the just the notion that you did
something for 12 months
consistently if nobody interacts with it
i c i would honestly challenge anybody
on the planet
if you did something every day for 365
days like some creative exercise and
posted it
if you couldn't like create like one
commercial opportunity off the back of
that
i just don't think it's possible like
just the very like
the fact that you know this is like
proof of work and the concept of a cv
taken to a new level
the idea that hey even nobody's
interacting with this stuff you know
what i'm capable of because you've seen
me do it every single day so
like at the very least someone might
bring me into their business to help
uh to help them achieve that result
whether it's
dude jim o'shaughnessy on the show the
other day he said
he hired some new guy who's maybe from
bangladesh or india or something
didn't need to see his cv he just
followed him on twitter for nine months
looked at what he was putting out on
twitter and thought
that's my guy that's proof of work i
can't remember who it was that said
the top nine images on your instagram
grid
are the new cv yeah well it's not
actually all that far off
and um here's an interesting start
talking about the consistency thing so
90 of podcasts that are launched don't
make it past episode three
and of the ten percent that make it past
episode three
ninety percent don't make it past
episode 20
so simply by producing 21 podcasts
you're in the top percentile of all
podcasters ever
one percent right yeah
just crazy man i don't think people
understand that like that is crazy
um yeah and just
yeah the you're in the top one percent
and you've
um already like started to
create effects that you are you know
unaware of at that point like three
podcast episodes
you could make the argument that six
months time nothing's going to be
different but 21
is like it's not it's not 17 episodes
different it's like
an order of magnitude more compelling
convincing and i think that
that is you know you talk about matthew
principle you talk about anything that's
like
your thousand and first image isn't like
a plus
one it's a plus they're 150 yeah
it's just different beast let's say that
someone makes it happen then or they
start to make it happen they start to
feel that hockey stick
kick in how do you have a strategy for
sustaining
power laws and keeping inflection points
going
you know i think this is a
it's kind of non-tangible advice but
it's like you've honed your gut
to the point where you can get there
then
i think it some of it comes back to like
trusting
your instinct so
like that point in time where i'm
producing stuff and no one's interacting
with it
it's it's all like information
information that's being fed to you in
some way
um i'm working on a project right now
with a few guys and
we had an idea we went from like idea in
a discord channel to execution in like
two hours it's like here's the idea
something like mock this up do that do
that do that
and you get you arrive at this place and
it's three people i really trust
and we're all like man we did that so
fast that can't be right right that
can't be the
it can't be the answer like let's go and
explore a bunch of other stuff
and we'll come back in 10 days and it's
like no the first thing was the right
thing
because it's not two hours of work right
it's
it's the collective 30 years of
experience between all of you that
produce that first result
but you for whatever reason your
you know your gut needs proof from your
mind that it was right so you have to go
and pursue these like
ridiculous angles and then you end up
back at the place you
began so i think when you've gotten to
any inflection point understanding that
there's some
intangible you have some intangible
ability or you have
uh an instinct that allowed you to
create that result in the first place
inflection point's there for a reason
right the hockey sticks happened for
something
so your ability to like lean into your
instinct
and keep like even if it feels
at times like you're i don't know
abandoning
the set of rules that got you you know
there's there's plenty of people that
said that like what got what get you
what got you here won't get you there
it's the second set of boosters falling
off or whatever you
analogy want to use i like that one but
the
idea that
especially if it's like all of the
examples we're talking about is
network effects right and you have
a huge number of people paying attention
to what you're doing it's then like
trusting your instinct
and going back to those people with like
the newest iteration of your instinct
get feedback from them and then if
you're right yeah you just keep going
to continue the space shuttle analogy
going
even if the booster rockets do get added
on the payload remains the same
right right you know it's still the same
astronauts that are at the front
or it's still the same payload that's
being delivered into space
it's just how am i going to propel this
now so many of the things
that i think we've talked about today
are around
this weird combination of
self-confidence
sort of trust in what you are the
intangibles the the source code
of all of the different experiences that
have kind of just
made something that you have that you
offer the market that maybe is a little
bit difficult to define
having faith in that consistency the the
importance of consistency because
without consistency you can't iterate
and consistency is basically just shots
at goal the more shots at goal you take
the more goals that you potentially
going to score
and then there's this sort of beautiful
this beautiful perspective that you need
to be able to see the extraneous stuff
to be able to observe all of the
different opportunities but not get
bogged down in the opportunities
and yeah i um
it's like the essentialism thing right
like what is the vital few
areas of contribution that will make the
vast amount of difference
eighty percent of the effort that you
put in will eighty percent of the
results that you will get will come from
20
of the of the inputs but a lot of the
time we can flip that around and we
start wasting so much time
getting distracted with the new
opportunities or getting distracted with
the idea that there does need to be
something different or changed
losing faith in what it is that we do
stopping being consistent because we've
got so many other different projects
coming in and
different opportunities that we start to
slow down and um
the beauty that you have with the
leverage is that
one good idea iterated
consistently is essentially an endless
gold mine it's
it literally is a bottomless pit of
opportunities
and yeah as you said i need new ideas i
need to keep things
fresh but there is a core to what it is
that you offer the market and continuing
to stay with that is important
and this somewhere in between all of
this is the
x factor right it's the right amount of
variety the right amount of explore and
the right amount of exploit
that you have between them i need a
little bit of new but i need to stay the
same
i need to observe the new stuff that's
coming out and add on the things that
work but i also need to not get
distracted by shiny things
and this is um i think it's cal newport
to talks about this again
he says that the best business people in
the world are essentially complex
hard to replicate decision engines
that's all that they are
they have tons and tons of intangibles
and input data
and they are able to like the old style
accounting machines that feed out a
piece of paper
and they'll just feed out one number and
that number is what you're supposed to
do next
and i think that trusting your gut and
allowing that to come through
gets rid of a lot of the noise a lot of
people that get into online business and
create their economies as well we're so
cerebral we're so
pulled along by the raw horsepower that
we have cognitively
that you think i'm just gonna think my
way out of this problem yeah yeah
but especially as time goes on perhaps
thinking your way into
a solution at the beginning is a good
idea but
as time goes on you have so much
embodied
understanding of the stuff that you're
doing i'm sure that you get this
when you create certain pieces of your
work
you'll feel like it's good
you'll it'll be sensed somewhere in you
i get that with podcasts i just know
like dude that was like a dance or like
a
like a football match or a beautiful mma
fight or something like that it was it
was amazing
why i don't know i don't [ __ ] know
okay i just but i know that it was
and that trusting your gut especially as
the experience continues to go
focusing on simplicity focusing on the
things the core of the very very
business
and then keeping that perspective i
think that that's such a powerful
message yeah
it's worked so far
[Music]
what is the price that you have to pay
to be jack butcher
uh i think
anybody obsessed with anything it's get
it's hard to turn off i think that's the
um the crazy thing
about operating in a leveraged
environment as well
is you can always be doing 100 times
better right it's like you don't come
home from work and you're like
day's done you know it's like i could
have used a different word in that
sentence and the result would have been
like you know 2x so i think it's
the price is like is just constantly
critiquing your behavior in
you know in a healthy way hopefully you
can definitely get
into dicey scenarios where you don't um
you know don't balance your health
properly with what you're doing on the
business side but
without that i don't know if i don't
know if
the result is as possible it's um
a healthy obsession i hope um
what else is that it's it's also the
like
i'm sure you go back to your first
interviews and you're like you just
cringe at
some of the stuff you said like even
three months ago and you're like
man what a donkey like i just i just did
that poorly now with the information i
have acquired since then um
i think yeah there's like
self-examination and
uh just recognizing that you're
basically never going to get it right
and if you're
if you're there's a great quote by ira
glass
he talks about taste it's like the
reason creative people get into
the pursuits they get into is because
they have great taste
but as your craft evolves your taste is
always going to outpace your craft
so you're going to look at your stuff
you're like that sucks man but
like if you're improving that's why
right it's like it's this unattainable
goal you're always chasing
and just to fall in love with the with
the fact that the goal post is moving as
opposed to
like scoring i think that's the
that's the key and everybody deals with
it differently or people have
different levels of uh ability to do
that
um but slowly you get better at
recognizing that
it's just a sequence of today's and the
goal post is always going to move
there's a
story about the buddha and one of his
most famous quotes which is life is
suffering and the word that they have
for suffering is dukkha
but some scholars contest that dukkha
doesn't translate to suffering it
translates to unsatisfactoriness
life is unsatisfactoriness and this
relates to how we are evolved that
there is built into the substrate of our
being
a degree of unsatisfactoriness every
experience that you have will be
tarnished just
slightly we're anticipatory beings we
imagine this amazing thing
and then we get there and there's we
should have had it blended instead of a
iced mojito or there's a little bit of
sand between my toes or i wish that i'd
gone for the medium well steak instead
of the medium rare steak
even though it's almost perfect there's
always something because that's how it's
built in
and this duker bias as i call it
as soon as you realize that is a feature
of life not a bug there isn't something
wrong
with the situation the situation is
always going to have something wrong
with it
as soon as you realize that from a
creator's side which i'd never even
thought of before
the the podcast that you produce is
always going to be a little bit
more [ __ ] than the podcast that you
could have produced yeah
exactly like there's answers i've given
on this conversation i'm like
subconscious track like you sound like
an idiot
and while i'm giving the answer yeah
yeah yeah but
like yeah i'll do another one in a
couple of weeks time and maybe i'll
answer a little differently
yeah there's just a fascinating
yeah a fascinating thing that i think
also has been confirmed
through the symptoms of building a
network where you get introduced to
people who are just
like you admire at a ridiculous level
and then they tell you stuff and you're
like what you're just human as well
yeah you're just the same you're just
struggling with the same stuff dude
listen to sam harris is on lex
friedman's
show right like lex is crushing it in
the podcast space i think he's fully
filled the void that rogan's left on
youtube and
congrats to him sam harris now that
jordan peterson's been ticked off the
list like harris is next on there for me
as
sort of dream guests and lex says
precisely what you've just said there
you know this is a guy who does 12 hours
a 12 hours ish of deep work every single
day self produces his own podcast
terrifying iq blah blah blah all this
stuff and he says exactly the same thing
that he's berating himself during the
podcast
for a thing that he's saying as he's
saying it on the podcast
and he's chastising himself for how
stupid and dumb
i've just said this thing to sam harris
what a [ __ ] idiot like that's
how his inner monologue works and
to concede that no matter how much
better you get no matter how many more
capacities you gain
as you said the yardstick for where
you're supposed to get to is always
going to be out of reach of where you do
because it is a feature not a bug that
duke bias
there's a uh i think it's oscar's speech
matthew mcconaughey have you
seen that one he said who's your hero he
said me in 10 years i think he says
and he's like he's going to be my hero
in 10 years me in 10 years
like that's uh like just a great model
to think
you know every day is some feedback loop
that's gonna
put you in a better position tomorrow
that's essentially the game
i think a community is really important
for this and
i i can't think of any examples now but
you could imagine a creator perhaps you
didn't necessarily have as much direct
audience feedback
as you do and fortunately as i do
this is the important thing and you know
to everyone that's listening
i've taken this on board as a creator
understanding what
i really appreciate from people that
consume my content
the friction now from me hearing
something or seeing something that's
good
on the internet and congratulating the
person that created it
has essentially dropped to zero someone
that i don't know
someone that's got basically no
followers someone that's got a million
followers i'll happily send an email
to lex friedman's old public or text
michael o'malley's and say yo dude if
you speak to
lex tell them about this it doesn't
[ __ ] matter but on the off chance
that it does reach that person
or whatever someone that you do know
that's great that's just launched a new
business
those bits of feedback that
congratulations or that reinforcement
about them doing something good
is worth a hundred thousand plays
and it's worth ten thousand subscribers
that is a big
big impact on so if you love what your
favorite creators do my advice is to
tell them
because if you don't you risk them
running out of gas
and no longer producing the thing that
you love from them
co-signed duplicated what drives you
now you've reached some degrees of
financial success that i imagined
previously would have perhaps only been
a dream to you
what drives you now
uh i think getting into
a situation where you can pursue your
curiosity
with a higher degree of conviction is
that
is like that's a nice feedback loop to
get into
so um the project i was talking about
before where we
there's four of us and we made this
thing in a couple of hours
years ago i wouldn't have uh i wouldn't
have gotten myself into a situation like
that because it's like maniacal
focus on the you know the engine
that is creating the free time to do
stuff like that so
it's definitely there's two sides of it
one is the family time so how do i
build a business and a life that is like
equally equally prioritizes
doing things that can help people i've
never met and spending a bunch of time
with
family and then the second part is like
just by continuing to pursue your
curiosity you
i have proof for this now that
opportunities that i never
knew existed will show up so it's just
like
that is the inherent drive the thing
that you have to come back and remind
yourself is like i don't even know
what it is i want or what situation i
want to be in but if i keep doing this
thing that i'm good at
stuff that i never could have possibly
imagined is just gonna pop
up so and that that's we go back to this
is pointless thing it's like
knowing that back then i knew it by
osmosis
because i listen to podcasts and read
people's words that have experienced it
but that um
yeah just just uh trusting the fact that
that is going to stay true
if you stay true to the process is uh
is definitely a driving force having
faith in your future self like that
matthew mcconaughey said it
on his oscars speech and i've got a
buddy who
likes to buy fast cars and spend a lot
of money and whenever he gets asked dude
you know
you're fairly highly asset
sort of leveraged up here there's a lot
of your net worth in depreciating
vehicles that have got four wheels and
he says it doesn't matter future andrew
will pay for it
and his self-confidence
that whatever the situation is that he
will always get it sorted moving forward
i i mean his verge is on pathological
which is also admirable but
not necessarily scalable or replicable
yeah exactly it's not something that
everyone can do immediately
but having faith that the small amount
of success or the large amount of
success that you've had
has been due to something innate in you
that isn't there
in the market already and going okay
well
let's go you know let's drill down and
see just how
long i can ride this until the wheels do
come off or how far i can fly this
rocket ship until
i do run out of boosters because i don't
know i mean do you ever see
an end for the creator economy here
is it we're talking decades of time here
right
yeah 100 i think it's uh
i think it's like a huge
transformational shift like the people
that would have
asked me those questions three years ago
like oh what are you doing you're a
motivational speaker
now i run into them they'll be like how
do i build a how do i build
like an online business or how do i
start to like
put myself out there online in a way
that's going to
create opportunity to people or it's it
feels like
there's been a seismic shift i think um
covered last year that's just it may
have been debatable a year ago but now
it's not right it's like you are
your identity is at the very least 50
online and 50 offline maybe that wasn't
true before but now it is
and i think everybody
creator economy is just such a i mean
such a broad term
and what i think it really means is is
like you know people participating in
something with skin in the game
online that that feels to me like
a fairly broad but accurate description
of what we're talking about
and yeah that
like jim o'shaughnessy is a great
example it like that
guy that got hired for his podcast was
because he's out there
putting his work out and um
this like he didn't do that to get a job
on jim or shaunicy's podcast
right he just happened to have one
because he was doing this online for a
period of time
i think the more evidence that builds up
in pop culture for things like that
happening the more people will start to
chew it the more
like the more of a positive some game
this becomes
and uh yeah you could go down a rabbit
hole about
what the eventual
like spread of resources looks like as a
result of that and i think all the
platforms and things make a lot of those
decisions and like how people get
rewarded for what they do but
i do not think it's going anywhere to
the extent i would say
um like universal basic income at some
point
is it is a
inevitability because of like the amount
of efficiency that will be
achieved on the like on a commercial
scale by any commodity business
and then like we'll have a huge shift to
you know people needing to fill their
days with
stuff you either create content or you
consume content that's gonna be yeah
that's gonna be the divide man
awesome it's been a long time coming i'm
very glad that i've got you on uh people
want to check out your stuff where
should they go
uh twitter is the best place to start so
jack butcher and
visualize value on twitter and then you
can find everything else from there
jack butcher ladies and gentlemen dude
thank you so much
hey thanks it's a pleasure thank you
very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace